I want to put this into perspective uh
Eric the actor I try to always get him
work so John Strauss who's the executive
producer of in plain sight I mean this
is a guy probably could have retired he
wrote something about Mary did you know
that I did not know okay oh he wrote all
the Tim Allen Santa Claus Series so that
you're talking about heavy this guy's a
major player and now he's negotiating
with Eric the actor now because he liked
us right because he wanted to do
something he thought would be fun John
you there Howard I'm glad you're
enjoying it yeah you can't say I didn't
warn you I told you this was going to
all backfire on you and you were gonna
hate it you were
correct right all right let me explain
to you John's dilemma he wants to come
through and give Eric the part but Eric
has written a letter that has many
different demands and it may it would
make JLo blush JLo's like who's Eric's
representative I want him and so and now
we're talking about a part that is four
lines that I assume would take less than
a day to shoot am I correct you are
absolutely right how many hours would
you say you've devoted to this seriously
I mean just like worrying literally
there have been nights when I've
awakened in the middle of the night
worrying about is this really going to
go down and am I going to have to hire a
backup actor and I've got my staff
working on the Travel arrangements and
all the different options John I'm
embarrassed to ask you this is there an
Arby's or McDonald's close to the set
okay will there be a runner available to
drive as far as needed to go there can
you imagine now he's had to go out and
look for Arby's all right so here's the
thing we don't know where the particular
location is going to be although I will
say this is New Mexico Co chances are
there will be a McDonald's or an Arby's
somewhere but you're not willing to
commit to knowing it Eric is there also
of course there is yeah there's food
everywhere well why McDonald's and
Arby's oh the grease Robin I'm trying to
answer questions shut up I am just
wondering that one is not necessary
Eric does not want any contact with some
of the dangerous wildlife that inhabit
that region including black bears
mountain lions coyotes Bobcats spiders
werewolves or any venomous snake
let me let me alter that okay you want
to take out werewolves
well the only actually had him Wikipedia
and there actually are legitimately
werewolves in Albuquerque
all right listen to me Eric why would
you believe Wikipedia that there's
werewolf you know there's werewolves New
Mexico it was a real creature that lived
in Albuquerque New Mexico Johnny said
there's real werewolves in New Mexico
and you believe them
I mean Eric really all right I'm taking
that out of the contract Eric they can't
protect you from werewolves Eric you
know there are no werewolves do you
think there are vampires I don't know if
there are or not around here all right
well it's true he hasn't been many
places that's true have there been any
recent uh werewolf deaths reported in
Albuquerque John uh not to my knowledge
very difficult though to put all this in
writing since they don't exist but if
you could put some language in there
that says that you can assure us there
will be no werewolf attacks and that
Eric won't be bitten and turned into a
werewolf I I don't know that I can put
that in writing all right again if we're
if we've gone all this way and this is a
deal breaker I need to know all right no
I don't think it is well now that I'm
thinking about it though a werewolf bite
might be good yeah he'd get in the
movies he could be in that Twilight
movie there you go all right John can I
get back to running my show now yeah get
back to running your show and uh let's
hope you don't shoot during a full moon
all right thank you Eric
thank you bye for now
thank you